so let's say that i have a vial of some
mystery liquid right over here and i
want to start figuring out what's going
on there
and the first step is to think about is
it just one substance or is it a mixture
of multiple substances
and the focus of this video is a
technique to
separate out the substances to
understand at least how many there are
and this technique generally is called
chromatography but we'll focus on
thin layer chromatography which is the
most common that you might see
but other variations of chromatography
like paper chromatography
operate on very similar principles so
what we're going to do
is set up on top of
something like glass or plastic we're
going to put a thin layer
of a solid polar substance
now what you typically do is put a thin
layer of
silica gel that's the most common solid
polar substance that folks use and it's
also porous
and the fact that it's porous is really
important because we're going to want
liquid
to have capillary action and travel up
through it
now the silica gel as i mentioned this
thing
is very polar
now we're going to do is take some of
our mystery substance let's see it's
this color right over here
and we're going to place a dot of it on
that silica gel you then want to take
this plate that has the silica gel
on it and that little dot of our mystery
substance
and then you want to dip just one end of
it in a solution
and what's really important is that the
solution is less polar than the silica
gel
less polar here and we'll talk a little
bit about what
happens depending on how polar this is
now usually this is going to be a very
shallow amount
of this solution which as we'll see will
be
something of a solvent and you usually
want to put it in a closed container
like this
so that this fluid down here doesn't
evaporate out
and then what do you think is going to
happen well as i mentioned
this is a porous substance here and so
you're going to have capillary action
this fluid at the bottom is going to
move upwards through the silica gel
through those little pores in the silica
gel
this is the stationary phase why do we
call it that well because it's not
moving
and you can imagine we would call this
less polar solvent
the mobile phase because that is
traveling through
the silica gel and it's trying to it's
picking up some of this mystery
substance
and it's transporting it and let's say
this mystery substance
is made up of two different things if
something is
more polar that means it's going to be
more attracted to the stationary
phase which is very polar and so it's
not going to travel
that far while the parts of our mystery
substance that are less polar
they're not going to be attracted to the
silica gel as much
so they're going to travel further with
the solvent so maybe it might go
like that and you would run this until
your mobile phase makes a good way
to the top of your silica gel right over
here
now just looking at this and the reason
why it was called chromatography is when
they originally did this they were
actually separating out
various tissues in vegetation that had
different colors and though chroma
is referring to the various colors but
it doesn't necessarily even have to
refer to things that have different
colors or sometimes you might need a uv
light to see them but when you run thin
layer chromatography you will see
that your original dot will have
traveled to various degrees with your
solvent
and then will now be multiple dots
depending on how many things were in
your original mixture and as i just
mentioned
this thing right over here this is the
less polar thing
is going to travel further than the more
polar thing
more polar constituent substance because
the more polar thing is
is more attracted to silica gel which is
stationary
and there is a way to quantify how far
these things traveled
relative to your solvent and that's
called a
retention factor retention
factor which the shorthand is
r subscript f and it's just defined as
the distance traveled
by the salute
salute divided by
the distance traveled
by the solvent
and we need to be clear it's not the
distance traveled by the solvent in
total
it's the distance traveled by the
solvent from this
origin from where we applied this dot
right over here
so past the origin
and let me label that as the origin
so what would it be in this situation
where to help us there
we would have to get out a ruler so the
retention
factor for substance a
right over here so i'll put that dot
there label that a
would be equal to the distance traveled
by the solute
which we can see it traveled
one centimeter one centimeter
over the distance traveled by the
solvent past
the origin and so that is going to be
we see it traveled 5 centimeters past
the origin
so 1 centimeter over 5 centimeters which
is the same thing is
0.2 and then the retention factor
for substance b is going to be equal to
how far did it travel well it traveled
three centimeters out of a total
of five centimeters for the solvent past
this origin plus where we put the sample
right over there
5 centimeters which is equal to 0.6
so notice in this situation the more
polar substance had a lower retention
factor than the less polar substance
and that makes sense because our
stationary phase
is more polar than our solvent
and so the things that are more polar
were harder to move
by the less polar solvent